Facebook's parent company meta announced
major layoffs Facebook's parent company
is giving another 10,000 workers the act
that I take full responsibility for this
decision um you I'm the founder and CEO
Facebook is dead at least that's what
most YouTubers want you to think
Facebook used to be the cool social
media platform that came and slapped
around Myspace and put it in its grave
Zuck has been through political
controversies government lawsuits and
watched while his company lost $700
billion in market cap in just a few
months on top of that let's be honest
Facebook just isn't cool anymore no one
uses it so it can't be making that much
money well the truth is much more
complicated but before we dig into the
numbers we need to understand what
happened on November 9th 2022 at the
time meta's stock was down by more than
75% and the Facebook parent company
losing nearly 70% of its value this year
alone an insane drop for a company worth
over $1 trillion and considered one of
the best tech companies in the world
things looked bad and Zuck knew he had
to start making tough decisions so he
made a really aggressive move he laid
off 133% of meta's Workforce more than
11,000 people and then he put a hiring
freeze in place that would last for
months this wasn't easy but it had to be
done meta had simply grown too big over
the past few years and the spending was
getting out of control Zuck wrote a
letter to the impacted employees
apologizing it seemed like meta could be
downward spiral losing money firing more
people all bad signs but then something
remarkable happened the company's stock
price started climbing and went on one
of the greatest rallies in Tech History
over the next 9 months the stock
appreciated by
270% Mark Zuckerberg personally made
over 80 billion and the company was once
again worth nearly a trillion dollars
it's an incredible comeback story but
those November layoffs were just the
first piece of the puzzle there are
actually 10 important reasons why
Facebook lives on and you should never
assume Zuck is down for the count let's
go through them one at a time the most
obvious reason that Everyone likes to
hate on Facebook is that the site just
feels dead plenty of American
Millennials will tell you the same story
they loved using Facebook in college but
over the past few years the site has
become complete junk and they don't
check it anymore I'm certainly in that
group and even though the narrative
feels true the numbers tell a very
different story see Meta as a whole is
still growing their overall user base
and the metrics are staggering 2.93
billion people use meta products daily
and 3.7 1 billion people use their
services monthly and those numbers are
still growing by tens of millions of
people now to be fair a lot of that
growth is coming from Instagram and
WhatsApp but not all of it Facebook
proper the Blue app that feels totally
dead is still growing most recently they
added 16 million users to hit 1.98
billion total daily active users just
insane numbers most of this growth is
happening outside of the United States
and Europe though places like India
Brazil and Indonesia are newer to
Facebook and still ramping up their
usage but most importantly the the idea
that Facebook is dying in America is
just wrong the usage numbers are flat
but they aren't declining which means
that people who do like posting on
Facebook are sticking around too many
people are still pattern matching
against the early days of social
networking before Facebook Myspace was
the dominant social network and it was
huge but when Facebook came along
Myspace quickly became irrelevant and
really did die off Facebook is a
different Beast though the network is so
large that there are still plenty of
thriving communities on there that will
likely never leave it might have lost
its social relevance and not be seen is
the cool Social Network anymore but for
certain groups of people it's still
valuable okay so if the core Facebook
app isn't dying what about Instagram
this is our third narrative violation
Instagram is actually doing just fine
make no mistake the app has been under
assault for years Snapchat was the first
big disruptor in the space it started as
a messaging app and didn't look like a
competitor to Instagram at all but when
Snapchat rolled out stories it became
clear that Instagram had a real
competitor disappearing stories had a
unique value proposition compared to
Instagram they were ephemeral so you
didn't need to think think so hard about
what you would post photos and videos
would go out to a smaller audience
usually just your real friends and then
disappear after 24 hours if you didn't
look perfect in that photo who cares
Instagram had been taken over by
professional models and influencers who
had spend hours taking photos with
expensive cameras and perfect lighting
the average person just couldn't compete
so they started to feel less confident
about posting on Instagram Snapchat
offered a return to the Casual posting
that Drew people to Instagram in the
first place but that made it a threat
snap's valuation was climbing into the
billions and Zuck was starting to get
worried that the company would be a real
threat now Zuck Had A playbook for
dealing with these pesky upstart social
networks he' just buy them in 2012 he
bought Instagram for $1 billion and then
two years later he bought WhatsApp for
an insane $16 billion but that Playbook
was getting stale first off the CEO of
snap Evan Spiegel was already a wealthy
guy he didn't need zuck's money and more
importantly I think he liked the idea of
going toe-to-toe with the biggest name
in social media the government was also
complicating things for Zuck the Federal
Trade Commission had gotten really
aggressive about policing big tech
companies every acquisition would go
under the microscope and most would have
to deal with complicated lawsuits so
buying snap was off the table and Zuck
was left with only one option copy
Snapchat's killer feature stories in
August of 2016 Instagram added
disappearing stories to the app the
launch was widely criticized hardcore
Instagram users didn't like how the app
was changing and lots of people thought
it was anti-competitive for Zuck to copy
a rival company but like it or not the
plan worked they didn't kill Snapchat
but they hurt the pretty seriously one
report showed that Snapchat's growth
slowed 82% after Instagram stories
launched basically if you were on
Instagram you now didn't need to go to
Snapchat to watch stories so the app
could keep on growing and it did
Instagram now has over 2 billion monthly
active users and zck was able to repeat
this Playbook when Tik Tok started
pressuring them which brings us to our
fourth narrative violation everyone
thinks Tik Tok is going to
singlehandedly dismantle zuck's social
media Empire but that's simply not true
Tik Tok is wildly popular the the app
has a billion monthly active users and
has clearly captured the social
relevance that Facebook and Instagram
used to dominate it's the cool app right
now but Zuck has been aware of the Tik
Tok threat for years all the way back in
2016 Zuck tried to buy musically the
predecessor to Tik Tok and when he
couldn't he launched a directly
competitive app called lasso in 2018 the
acquisition almost went through even
though musicly was pretty small by
Facebook standards they had a strong
foothold in China and Zuck wanted to
expand there back in 2016 China wasn't
the geopolitical Hot Topic it is today
every big Tech CEO saw China's massive
population and their staggering economic
growth as a huge opportunity getting
Facebook products into China would be a
great new engine of growth for the
company if they could pull it off so
Zuck started pursuing the deal most tech
CEOs would just dispatch someone on
their team to go figure out China but
not Zuck he became obsessed with the
problem and took some really aggressive
measures he learned Mandarin so he could
speak directly to Business Leaders and
government officials in China uh
sure he also visited the controversial
ten square and went jogging with Chinese
Communist Party officials no Tech CEO
would do something like this today it's
just too politically complicated but
back then it was worth a shot Zuck
invited the founder of musicly alexu to
visit Facebook's menow Park headquarters
he also flew his team out to Shanghai to
tour musically's offices there but the
deal fell through probably for political
reasons and the two companies have been
fighting it out in the short form video
Market ever since once musically had
rebranded to Tik Tok and really started
blowing up Zuck knew he had to do
something to stem the bleeding so ran
the stories Playbook all over again
Instagram launched reals a direct Tik
Tok competitor in August of 2020 and the
usage has been growing ever since it
took a few years to really have an
effect but recent data shows that Tik
tok's growth is basically plateauing now
there's always a risk when these new
features launch they could cannibalize
app usage and overall time spent on the
app could basically be flat every minute
spent on Tik Tok is a minute not spent
on Instagram so it's really important
that zuck's plan actually expands
Instagram's usage but that's exactly
what's happening happening reals is
growing like crazy and only increasing
the amount of time people spend on
Instagram and at the end of the day the
thing that matters most is revenue
Instagram res will only be a success if
it can make lots of money but that plan
seems to be working Zuck announced that
reals is making $3 billion per year just
shy of the $4 billion Tik Tok made in
2021 the key thing to remember here is
that zuck's goal is not to kill Tik Tok
outright well maybe it is but he doesn't
need to do that to be successful he just
needs to stop Instagram users from
switching over to Tik Tok and it looks
like the plan's working it's not just
Facebook and Instagram that are
bolstering meta's resilience though Zuck
also has a complete sleeper app that
most people forget about our fifth key
driver WhatsApp when Zuck paid $16
billion for WhatsApp in 2014 everyone
thought he was crazy after all the
company had just 55 employees at the
time but since the acquisition WhatsApp
has turned into a monster with more than
2 billion daily active users it's not as
flashy as Tik Tok or Instagram but it's
steadily growing in terms of popularity
and influence as big social network
become increasingly driven by algorithms
it's harder and harder to connect with
people you actually know lots of people
who use social media apps never post at
all in fact back in 2021 a study found
that just 25% of Twitter users produced
97% of all tweets on the site if you're
just an average User it's hard to keep
up with people whose job it is to create
content but WhatsApp helps bridge the
gap for billions of people they can
connect with people on an individual
basis or hang out in smaller trusted
group chats where no one is getting paid
to post the smaller social networks that
pop up on WhatsApp are extremely sticky
and keep people using the app for years
it's the last real place to check in
with your close friends on a regular
basis no algorithms needed these three
core apps form the backbone of what meta
refers to as its family of apps they all
have billions of users and collectively
help produce over $100 billion in
Revenue every year but this Revenue
comes from ads and meta's ads business
has been under assault for the past few
years which leads us to our sixth
narrative violation on September 16th
2020 Apple officially released iOS 14 to
most consumers it was a pretty boring
update the biggest addition was
homescreen widgets a feature that had
been available on Android for years it
also made the incoming call notification
a bit smaller not exactly groundbreaking
stuff but down the road from copertino
Zuck was sweating in his Meno Park
headquarters see behind the scenes Apple
had just thrown a massive wrench in the
trillion doll online advertising
industry it was a small change that most
iPhone users barely noticed but it was a
huge change to how digital ads were
served up on iPhone apps like Facebook
and Instagram basically there would now
be a popup notification in every app
that asked the user if they wanted to be
tracked by the app they were using this
was framed as a way to give iPhone users
more control over their privacy but
really it was just a massive shot at
Facebook the popup gave you two options
you could either ask app not to track or
allow tracking if you asked not to be
tracked you could still use the app
normally so most people click that but
this meant that advertisers could no
longer tell if the people they were
advertising to were actually buying
their products the net effect of this
was that ad advertisers would spend less
since they couldn't be as sure that
their ads were working this had an
immediate impact on meta Zuck and his
team told investors that this change
would reduce their revenue by $10
billion per year it was a staggering hit
since this would basically translate to
$10 billion in lower profits too but
then something interesting happened
meta's stock actually went up this iOS
14 change from Apple is referred to as
app tracking transparency or at for
short and before ATT meta was in a great
position every conversion could be
measured determined istically if someone
saw an ad and then installed an app or
bought something on an e-commerce site
meta could draw a straight line from one
event to the next this is what made
Facebook advertising so powerful you'd
never get this level of precision with a
billboard or a Super Bowl ad the
explosion in these precisely measured
digital ads created entirely new
Industries advertisers switched from
thinking about the cost of an ad
campaign to focusing on how much revenue
could be generated directed consumer
Brands Grew From nothing into the
millions seemingly overnight and mobile
games produced billions of dollars of
Revenue hate it or love it precise
digital advertising created tons of new
business opportunities that would
otherwise have not existed but ATT
destroyed the link between advertising
and conversions the entire online
advertising industry was now
structurally less valuable but this
didn't kill online advertising outright
as many had predicted it would if you've
used Facebook or Instagram recently
you're obviously still seeing ads
probably more than ever even though the
advertising was less precise now the
overall pie was still growing and meta
was in a great position to capture that
as more people joined meta's family of
apps and started using features like
stories and reals more than ever before
the overall number of ads that they
could show grew which drove overall
Revenue growth the reason why goes
deeper than just meta is big though the
resilience of meta's AD business comes
from our seventh Point Zuck has an
incredible artificial intelligence
strategy when the generative AI boom
started a few months ago lots of people
were making fun of Zuck for picking the
wrong megat Trend to Anchor his company
to they said he was going to rename his
company again from meta to AI which to
be fair is funny but let's be honest he
wasn't asleep at the wheel when it comes
to AI he has a great team of AI folks
led by the legendary Yan laon and has
been releasing AI products for years the
impact of AI at meta will take two forms
the first is extremely boring but
important and the second is extremely
cool but less certain in the short term
let's start with the first Apple's app
tracking transparency change broke the
deterministic link between ads and
conversions the solution to this problem
is clearly artificial intelligence AI is
fundamentally probabilistic it's just a
bunch of data crunched together to
approximate statistical outcomes but
that's perfect for targeting
advertisements in a world where you have
imperfect data just like how the Tik Tok
algorithm feels scarily good at
predicting what you want to watch next
after using it for a few hours meta is
implementing the same Technologies to
predict what advertisements you are most
likely to click on this can backfire
though it's always weird when an ad
feels a little too relevant now most of
this is just confirmation bias you see
thousands of ads but you only notice the
one for the product that you were just
talking about some of it is just random
chance but AI algorithms will make this
happen more and more frequently weird
correlations between behavior in the app
who you're connected to and what you're
watching will all combine to surface
hyper targeted ads and some of those are
going to be a bit freaky but I don't
really have a problem with this I'd
rather see ads for stuff I'm interested
in than random junk and it's certainly
good for the businesses that need to
advertise in order to grow there are
tons of entrepreneurs out there who just
want to grow their businesses and
Facebook and Instagram are the most
reliable way to do it all this is great
for meta 2 Apple took away their ability
to precisely track ads but AI is making
up the difference so that's the boring
but important piece of meta's AI
strategy now on to the really exciting
part Zuck recently released llama 2
meta's open- Source large language model
it's like a free version of open ai's
chat GPT and hackers love it zck is
winning over hackers like George Hots
because there's a big fear right now
about one company controlling the future
of artificial intelligence open sourcing
llama gives anyone the ability to
permissionless develop new AI
applications it's a real power to the
people moment hackers get to run wild
with this new technology and build
whatever they want it's great but the
question is how does meta benefit from
open sourcing llama well there are a few
ways first it serves as a great
recruiting tool when a kid plays with
llama at home maybe they'll want to go
work at meta in the future but more
importantly it should help meta further
Advance their core advertising business
they ran this same Playbook with their
open source front-end software Library
react they obviously needed to build
highly performant websites but the
software framework wasn't core to their
business model so they open sourced it
then Community improvements to react can
roll into their core product generating
text from a large language model like
llama benefits meta immensely they can
use the system to automatically generate
lots of different taglines for ads and
then test those across the entire ad
Network to see what performs best and
ultimately if people are generating
content using AI systems they'll need to
share it somewhere and meta's networks
will benefit but generative AI could
still wind up being much more impactful
to Z long-term Vision Beyond just ads
and this is reason number eight remember
that terrible metaverse demo where it
looked like Nintendo Wii Graphics well
there were a few problems with that but
generative AI can really help here first
off the biggest burden when it comes to
developing immersive 3D worlds the kind
that you see in Grand Theft Auto and Red
Dead Redemption is always asset creation
it just takes a lot of time to build out
a big 3D World and that's why all the
current metaverse applications just feel
kind of empty but if generative AI
evolves to a point where textures
objects NPC dialogue trees and whole
worlds can automatically be generated it
might actually be a place where people
want to go and hang out you can see
glimpses of this with mid Journey every
time I generate a cool sci-fi image I
think of how fun it would be to run
around and explore that world generative
AI unlocks this but it's not zuck's
business to own the models that create
content in the metaverse he just wants
to build the headsets and network where
all this activity is happening and this
leads us to reason number nine for
zuck's recent comeback now make no
mistake the entire metaverse project is
still a huge gamble by Zuck just over
the last year meta lost $15.7 billion on
the project insane numbers and now
they're under pressure from Apple which
is set to release the Apple Vision Pro
headset soon early reviews suggest that
the Vision Pro will be a big step up
from what meta has been releasing with
the quest line of headsets but I
wouldn't count out Zuck yet I've gotten
lots of hate for my previous videos
about how apple and Microsoft were set
to challenge zuck's metaverse plans but
the goal of those videos was just to
illustrate how competitive the frontier
of technology is it's always a knockout
drag out fight and Zuck isn't giving up
anytime soon even though meta is losing
tens of billions of dollars developing
new VR headsets the game is far from
Over the Apple Vision Pro will cost 10
times as much as a meta Quest and apple
will likely struggle to manufacture
these things for the first few years in
order to ship the Vision Pro with such
an ultra high resolution screen Apple
has basically had to scale up a benchtop
production process that is still
extremely low yield that means that they
won't be able to mass-produce these
headsets quickly and meta will have time
to potentially catch up even though meta
is losing tens of billions of dollars
every year on the metaverse initiative
the company still produces more than
enough profit to cover those losses Zuck
actually believes in this thing and is
willing to see it through to the finish
line and that leads us to our final
Point Zuck is a Relentless competitor
and he's really in charge at meta his
biggest competitor in the online
advertising industry is Google and they
haven't really been able to ship
anything new in the past few years Zuck
on the other hand is able to move
extremely quickly still consider threads
it's still too soon to see how the
service will pan out but it shows how
aggressive he can be when he gets
competitive he saw an opportunity to
steal some of elon's market share and
then he immediately launched a clone of
Twitter while the service was
experiencing rate limiting issues now
there are a bunch of problems with
threads the core community on Twitter or
I guess x.com Now isn't really moving
over and it's unclear if Instagram users
really want to use a text based app like
threads the history of zuck's product
development strategy has been to give
users more immersive experiences
Facebook started with text updates then
people started posting photos on
Instagram soon that shifted to video
uploads and looping reels long term he
wants people using VR headsets to access
metaverse experiences these are
basically the opposite of a bunch of
text posts like you'd see on threads but
the important thing is that he launched
it he's running the experiment he's
shipping and he's also revitalizing his
personal brand I've always been a bit of
a fan of Zuck what he built with
Facebook in the early days was amazing
and he's executed incredibly well in the
years that followed but after the social
network came out in 2010 he started
being framed as a villain and a recluse
that's just not true though the robot
and alien memes are funny but don't
really reflect reality he does have a
sense of humor he does have a
personality and now it's starting to
come out agreeing to fight Elon Mosk is
a perfect example of this Zak is
starting to have fun and show people
that he's more than just a quiet Tech
CEO who knows if the fight will happen I
personally hope it does because it's
weird and funny and awesome but even if
it doesn't I think we'll be seeing a
different side of Zuck for a long time
to come and if you want to know more
about zuck's business strategy just
watch this video next thanks a lot